hello everybody and welcome to part one
of let's play penumbra the Black Plague
now I've heard that this one is much
much scarier than the last one so I'm
looking forward to it because overture
had like one scare the entire game and
that was the worm thing so I've already
got the settings going on i turn the
gamma down and I'm always gonna remember
to always have a glow stick so that you
guys can see but hopefully this will
make it more atmospheric and maybe a
little scarier for me okay
so let's get going oh no I don't need a
tutorial put without this knowledge Oh
without this foundation huh
you could not have the will to do what I
must now is this John Orr's is Howard I
followed my father to the Regent wastes
to uncover his secret huh you had to
know how far I was willing to go I was
there I found a disused mining shaft
yeah shelter from the storm you had to
know how desperate I was I was there I
was plagued by doubts fear I didn't see
that and aided by a madman red Oh is
that red had to know how long he'll is i
incinerated my best friend ha
red told me he wanted to die Billy you
got to know how guilty I felt I didn't
feel that guilty I ventured boldly on
words and was struck down by my own
heroics uh-huh you want to know how your
heroics
my heroics all of these things so human
so perfect
during its all I failed to do which I
must now ask of you Oh what is that
always asking me to do stuff for him
that's so like John I don't know if John
is his real name I've just been calling
him John
whatever he's John always gonna be John
the big pansy all right what do we got
here oh this looks scary Oh only one
light oh it's so dark in here
not
come on
the wall textures a little burning last
game let's see what Oh what's this oh
yeah oh so strong go I said go that
doesn't know
get your calcium oh yeah oh yeah always
gonna have this on um get out now I'll
get out what I want to get out well
what's all that noise
bring it on Oh coin yeah awesome getting
murdered
Oh No so for that scariet now ah yeah
smart Oh give me something though oh I
didn't mean my fists Oh what's in here
oh come in okay so
coming this way getting their flock this
up oh it must be a hammer or something
so I can get through that case
chicka-boom uh-huh tool yeah okay you're
a tool John [ __ ] all right boys
there this is Billy's old mattress for a
French toast I love french toast all
right so there's nothing here nothing
there this one so it's a whole lot of
nothing
God always a whole lot of all right
maybe maybe if I snap this off uh-huh
pencil up good all right well I'm not
even a little bit into the game and I
guess this is where it ends good I've
searched everywhere and found absolutely
that's been not at all
phenomenal I told myself when I started
this I wasn't gonna be nearly as stupid
as I was before but obviously I'm
breaking my promise so look I don't even
know I don't even know they're all right
we do this in segments this corner
is empty this corner Oh top shelf on
this corner is not is now empty look
good bow ah come on baby
so give me something maybe someone mr.
Dores no nope under the desk no no
behind the desk alright so today my tool
Oh coin oh I'm so stupid oh I'm so
stupid oh yeah oh I'm so stupid I never
check my inventory I never do I'll get
home okay let's swing back on me okay
just get stay
oh I never checked my inventory come on
oh so here that's right yeah
give me that
all right from now on I'm always gonna
check my in man I am dumb dumb dumb dumb
oh hey this this game's gonna take
forever if I'm going at this pace let go
get ready for a hundred and seventeen
part series God all right event
aw like I'm scared all arrows thank you
thank you so much
what's in here mmm uh-huh that looks
good I like that
Oh flash a body what the death what did
my game breaker was that supposed to
happen
how's weird salvation yay
I like a salvation bring it on what are
we all pop machine I love the pop oh
yeah Gatorade
shut battery
all right I do dad here
there there let's see
oh yeah I will
um
the atmosphere is a little better I like
it seems a little more intense but still
not enough to make me nervous
oh I got a coin so stop it oh yeah Oh
glub glub glub glub oh there's still ice
cold and drink it drink it by moving on
oh yeah collapsed watch your steps oh
you watch your step blocked up
thank you John oh you're so smart watch
your step ah God now dammit
alright that didn't happen oh no where's
it no oh come on
alas no think of a hot chocolate hot
chocolate old chemist Oswald
that's all security sensitive no organic
wood here okay duly noted
thank you thank you I bail I throw rocks
in here zone
die come on
Oh on a plank of wood that'll be come
here up get in there ah
dummy don't be like that Hey don't oh so
smart you'd do it if it's enough
oh yeah I shouldn't go that way I be
cold enough ah who wants some get out of
here
that's right Ravens flock to Bertha no
no it can get
Oh cherry that's my weapon I don't need
a hammer nothing got what's all this
more ketchup but puts a flare bag out
bag us san oh look I was trying one hand
stretched all the way out Oh can't do
that like a 10-pound weight oh cool it
okay alright that same school ha get it
the chair a you're coming with me Oh
milk wait nevermind I got a pause it
here thank you so much for watching this
is about part one of let's play the
number of the black leg I will see you
in part 2 thanks for watching bye bye